today's new member of the day is Saul
gassiness Saul thank you so much for
being a david pakman show member
membership along with patronage at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
the two number one funding sources are
really together I mean that member
support is the number one funding source
of the show you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership you can go
to patreon.com/scishow and if you ever
shop on amazon.com you can go to david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop
and that will send us a little kickback
for everything that you buy let's go to
the phones it's been a while since we
have gone to the phones of course six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty is the number let's go to our
first caller from the 208 area code
caller what's your name where are you
calling from and feel free to jump right
into your topic hi my name is Cole
Courtney um I also have a youtube
channel called Sophie ninja from Hale
I'd like to ask you about Alex Jones and
Mark dice what do you think about these
guys is some of the stuff they're
spreading around on YouTube um it's a
little outrageous if you ask me well
what specifically is outrageous about
what they're spreading around what you
have in mind well mark dives I've seen a
video he put up not too long ago
I think it's called liberalism is
terrorism also Alex Jones has been
saying some pretty crazy stuff about
civil uprise pretty much like the South
versus the north type of commentary yeah
and as your is your concern because you
think that they shouldn't be allowed to
be on saying this stuff or because
you're worried I'm getting vengeance by
it I still existent being provocateur as
if they're stirring things up and it
could cause a lot of trouble people
could get hurt
so how do we deal with that um I think
that like exposing him showing some of
the stuff that he contradicts himself
with
when he makes up stuff and then people
will show that he's wrong but yet he's
never really confronted with it I think
stuff like that to help I don't know
yeah I mean you know there's sort of two
views right one is you expose it
sunlight being the best disinfectant
others would argue and this has come up
when I've done interviews with
extremists as well
no you just ignore them and if everybody
ignored them they wouldn't have an
audience you know so there's two sort of
opposing views on that I don't really
know too much about mark dice but when
it comes to Alex Jones we found out
about a week or two ago that he's a
performance artist according to his own
lawyers so it's important not to take
him too seriously he's playing an act
which he denied but that corresponds
with my experience when I met him
remember I've told I think I've told the
story you've been here Pat where I met
him and it seemed to me like it was
absolutely a character he sort of
alluded to making a conscious decision
as to how extremist to be and then his
lawyer basically said the same thing and
then Alex Jones said no I'm a real guy
anyway I mean you're bringing up an
interesting point but oh and the
caller's actually gone already so
interesting but very interesting
question diverging opinions about how to
deal with that